[Música]
el presidente de Chile Gabriel borich
cumple un año en el poder un tiempo
difícil para el mandatario que terminó
el 2022 con un promedio de aprobación
del 36% muy por debajo del 50% de apoyo
con el que ascendió al tener una promesa
de cambio en este país no tuvo éxito Con
la nueva constitución y su agenda de
cambio Todavía no se ha reflejado en
ninguna reforma aprobada para hablar de
la gestión del mandatario y el porqué de
sus derrotas nos acompaña desde Santiago
Marta lagos ella es analista
internacional y directora de la encuesta
regional latino barómetro Gracias por
estar con nosotros aquí en France 24 a
pesar de que la mayoría de los chilenos
aprobaron el referendo para cambiar la
Constitución no respaldaron el borrador
que presentó el año pasado el consejo
Constituyente qué responsabilidad cree
usted que le corresponde al gobierno de
borich Y qué caminos le queda n al
mandatario
Bueno yo creo que efectivamente el
referéndum fue rechazado por ser una
propuesta demasiado liberal demasiado
progresista demasiado vanguardista y a
los chilenos les produjo susto el cambio
chile es un país que quiere cambio Pero
quiere pocos cambios quiere cambios
lentos quiere cambios no a esa velocidad
y no en esa magnitud eso creo que fue lo
que sucedió y la la responsabilidad del
gobierno me parece que es una
responsabilidad relativa no porque el
problema es que eso fue redactado de una
manera terriblemente independiente yo
diría el gobierno no tuvo capacidad de
poder influir en lo que se estaba
redactando más bien el sistema político
no tuvo posibilidades porque estaba
fundamentalmente dominado por
independientes y los partidos jugaron un
papel secundario lo mismo el gobierno
Entonces el resultado fue el resultado
de la gente que había sido elegida sí
Marta y como usted lo dice los chilenos
si quieren cambios pero no tan rápido en
medio de esto Cuál es el balance que
usted da de este primer año de borich
bueno primero hay que tener en cuenta
que chile tuvo presidentes terriblemente
exitosos hasta el año 2010
donde la aprobación de gobierno estaba
por encima del 50% a partir del año 2010
que fue la primera presidencia de el
gobierno de Sebastián Piñera las
presidencias a los gobiernos y la
presidentes han tenido aprobaciones muy
por debajo del 50% y el gobierno de
borich no es una excepción en eso es
decir este ya es el cuarto quinto
gobierno donde la aprobación de gobierno
es inferior al cincuenta por lo tanto
hay que mirarlo Desde esa perspectiva
estamos ante una época distinta del
desarrollo donde en el año 2011 empiezan
las protestas estudiantiles en este país
el año 2019 viene el estallido social y
las demandas de esas protestas no han
sido todavía respondidas y la aprobación
de gobierno es el castigo que la gente
le hace al gobierno y de no haber sido
capaces de responder esas demandas Pero
esto es un tema digamos del desarrollo
del país de la incapacidad de haber
respondido al por ejemplo el tema de la
salud por ejemplo el tema de la
educación que hoy día seguramente va a
haber un cambio gabinete Para volver a
sacar al ministro de Educación hemos
tenido la mayor cantidad de ministros en
el en la cartera de educación es un tema
difícil de resolver que no ha tenido la
respuesta que la gente está esperando
Entonces esto no es un problema de
izquierda o de derecha como digo van dos
gobiernos de derecha y dos gobiernos de
izquierda que han tenido
aprobación bajo el 50% muy por debajo
del 50% Pero además del estallido Social
que ustedes nos cuenta y al cual Boris
todavía no ha respondido con una
reformas otra de las críticas que ha
enfrentado el presidente es la situación
con los mapuches en la araucanía a pesar
de que había criticado el enfoque
militar que le había dado su predecesor
Sebastián Piñera Boris cuando asumió el
cargo continuó con ese enfoque que tanto
le valió esta aproximación en contra de
la caída o en contra de su popularidad
bueno efectivamente
la presidencia cometió un error inicial
pensando que el problema mapuche era más
el problema de la araucanía era más
simple de lo que aparentaba ser y
finalmente tuvo que recurrir a la misma
herramienta que habían usado los
gobiernos anteriores yo creo que ese
reconocimiento
es también un reconocimiento al hecho de
que este es un problema que lleva
doscientos años no
finalmente digamos todos los chilenos se
dieron cuenta que esto no es un tema que
se pueda solucionar con una política
pública o con una donación de tierras
Aquí hay una demanda
muy sentida de los pueblos originarios
que han sido ignorados históricamente y
todavía no tenemos la solución este
gobierno tampoco tiene la solución No
hay nadie en Chile que en este momento
tenga una propuesta de solución ese es
el problema Ah la política los partidos
los líderes los las universidades los
pensadores en fin la filosofía no han
sido capaces de encontrar una fórmula
que permita la pacificación de ese
conflicto no el reconocimiento de los
pueblos originarios de las Naciones las
primeras naciones esto es el balance
dentro de casa pero quiero que ahora nos
hable de la política exterior de Gabriel
borich porque a pesar de haber sido uno
de los líderes del estallido Social se
creía que iba a ser un claro líder de la
izquierda en América Latina sin embargo
se ha distanciado por ejemplo de lo que
ocurre en Venezuela en Nicaragua Cuál es
el balance de esta política exterior que
usted da
Bueno yo creo que respecto de su tema
del tema de Venezuela que me menciona yo
creo que hoy día en América Latina hay
dos izquierdas una izquierda que avala
las dictaduras de izquierda como
Nicaragua y van a su Venezuela y otra
izquierda que no avala la dictadura de
Venezuela y Nicaragua
y Gabriel borich Te ubica claramente en
la segunda no y Y seguramente la la
llegada a esta nueva izquierda
porque anteriormente todas las
izquierdas avalaban las dictaduras de
izquierda hoy día no es así me parece
que la llegada de esta nueva izquierda
produce esta digamos nueva posición de
la izquierda que es una izquierda de
distinta naturaleza que la anterior no
hay no hay una sensación de bloque se
acabó se cayó el muro de Berlín Por
decirlo no en América Latina no se había
caído el muro de Berlín Porque todavía
había una solidaridad
tacita esa solidaridad tácita hoy día se
quiebra con esta y respecto a la
política exterior Bueno yo diría acá el
tema de del liderazgo en América Latina
vamos a ver qué pasa con Lula no pero el
tema liderazgo con América Latina yo
creo lo que lo dejó muy claro Enrique
Cardozo cuando fue presidente de Brasil
en su momento en que le preguntaron Y
usted por qué no toma el liderazgo
América Latina y él respondió bueno
porque a mí apenas me alcanza el tiempo
para Brasil Ah yo creo que problemas que
tienen los países hoy día en América
Latina no alcanzan a ser respondidos por
los actuales gobiernos y Estados esa es
la razón por la cual estamos en el
conflicto y en el declive de la
Democracia que estamos y
el tiempo apenas alcanza para el propio
país bueno Y todavía quedan varios años
para ver cómo Boris hace entre su
política interna y la política exterior
para contribuir América Latina Marta
lagos Gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo América muchas gracias a ustedes
un gusto y a ustedes los invitamos a que
sigan conectados con France 24 porque en
segundos tenemos más noticias
internacionales
[Música]